eric you have a book that's coming out
right now we're filming this in august
but by the time this airs it'll be
september late september i believe and
your book is called the idea
the seven elements of a viable story for
screen stage or fiction
i'm curious what prompted you to write
the book yeah so i've been a
screenwriter for like 25 years and
for the last about 10 years i've been
teaching screenwriting i've been working
one-on-one with a lot of writers as like
a consultant or coach
and i've been just reading a lot of
scripts film and tv scripts many many
many many many scripts right so you in
trying to help writers and to try to
kind of codify principles of writing
which is always a touchy thing because
sometimes people feel writing can't
really be taught or shouldn't be taught
you know i i've really tried to figure
out what are the things that one really
needs in a story idea because people
don't necessarily seem to know when
they're writing but when someone reads
someone's script they often are having
negative reactions
and what are the reasons for those
reactions i really made it my business
to figure out like what are the sort of
essential things that people are
reacting to not only when they read a
script but when they even hear the idea
for a script because the reason the
book's called the idea is that i've
really come to believe that the most
important part of the process
most writers bypass too quickly which is
selecting the idea and understanding
what makes a viable idea
that is so important to the eventual
success of any project and then that
might seem obvious but the average
writer myself included tends to want to
get to writing they tend to want to just
start structuring outlining and writing
the script so you pick an idea you often
don't vet the idea with professionals or
friends or anyone you just kind of like
i sort of like this idea i think i'm
going to write this and then you go
about writing it
whereas in the industry if you have a
manager or an agent what i've learned is
they'll want you to run your ideas past
them before you even start one they
don't want you to spend your time and
energy on something they don't think
is viable in the marketplace to begin
with so if you're trying to write for
that marketplace if you're trying to get
or maintain a manager an agent and move
forward you know in like the hollywood
marketplace
what's going to happen to you is your
representatives are going to shoot down
a lot of your ideas which has happened
to me
and they're going to really stop you at
the idea stage and want to hear the log
line or the basic the basic premise or
pitch
so i as a writer having agents
had to live that lifestyle of i gotta
impress my agents first right once i'm
lucky enough to have one as someone
reading people's scripts as a kind of
consultant or teacher
i now realize what my agents were
thinking because most of the things
people bring to me
finish scripts
the most of the notes that i have on
their scripts are notes i would have had
on the basic idea if they had just
brought it to me when it was a log line
or a 30-second pitch or a one-page
synopsis the kind of thing you'd put in
a query
so
but most writers don't kind of realize
that because they haven't vetted the
idea with anyone so i've been blogging
for five to ten years now you know
little tips and things the little pieces
of wisdom that i feel i've come up with
having read all these scripts and seen
the kind of things that i see
writers doing
and the blog eventually led to the idea
to do a book and the book is about let's
focus on the idea what makes a viable
idea it's not a book about the whole
process of screenwriting it's not about
story structure per se it's not about
writing scenes it's not about navigating
the business although all those things
are touched on it is exclusively about
what makes a viable idea and let's slow
down writers and really work on getting
the idea right before we
you know write the script or even
outline the script so what makes a
viable idea
so i came up with this little acronym
of the word problem because i feel that
every story is really about a problem
and it's all about you know when
someone's reacting to your script or
your pitch or your log line what they're
mostly thinking consciously or not is
okay what's the problem with the center
of the story does this problem sound
really compelling and entertaining to
watch is an audience going to care about
this problem
that this main character or these
characters are trying to solve whether
it's film television or even commercial
fiction or theater i think the same kind
of basic premises of you know how story
and ideas for story work applies to all
of them which is why the title mentions
um stage and fiction
they're looking at what the problem is
what's the nature of the problem or
what's the nature of the goal for the
main character right
so i took problem and i created this
acronym from the letters in the word
problem and the book is basically a
presentation of these seven elements
that start with those seven letters and
those are the elements that i think
successful commercially viable stories
that would interest an agent a manager a
producer an editor etc
tend to have you want to hear what they
are
so it's just quickly and we can go
deeper if you want the problem at the
center of the story needs to be
punishing
relatable
original
believable
life-altering
entertaining
and meaningful
so some of those words i could have used
different words but they wouldn't fit
the problem so i kind of made it so they
all lined up with those seven letters
that's great and and did you before sort
of even formulating the idea for this
book no pun intended um go through other
scripts and really hone in on what's the
problem let's say some of the block bus
stores or maybe even indie films what
really is the core of this problem and
then work backwards well yeah i do that
all the time it's just a natural thing
whenever i'm watching anything
i am assessing what is the central to me
that's what the story is what's the
central problem here uh we could talk
examples if you want but pretty much any
genre it's about characters who are kind
of punished usually as they're trying to
resolve some situation and so it's just
become second nature to me to think in
terms of what's the problem at the
center of any
tv series tv episode movie story in
general and of course when i look at
someone's script or i just see the
logline even i'm like i said i'm looking
at what's the problem here and sometimes
the logline doesn't even make the
problem clear or it focuses too much on
the internal problem for the characters
because sometimes writers confuse like
internal character arc with external
problem and great stories generally have
both but the external problem is kind of
the part that people really want to know
about when they are assessing your idea
it's like the external problem has to be
really solid the internal arc is a
little more optional but you've got to
have that big external problem typically
in a commercial type project
and so that's what i'm talking about
more than the internal what the
character needs to learn and how they
need to grow stuff which is
the arc or the theme or the flaw you
know that kind of stuff sometimes we
writers tend to focus a lot on that and
make that drive all of our efforts and
what i've learned is it's it tends to be
better to let that stuff stay a little
flexible until you've gotten the sort of
external problem worked out and even
kind of structured out a bit because
sometimes your sense of what the theme
is or what the character's growth should
be will change and shift once you've
really explored the external problem the
external challenge that they're you know
every scene is typically about them
grappling with and trying to resolve
i love that you've chosen the word
punishing whether it was just a
coincidence because it starts with p but
because you're putting yourself in the
protagonist's shoes and it seems like if
you're looking through life through the
lens of that character that it is a
punishment for you know that that they
are enduring things that are unfair to
them so i like that you've chosen that
as because it really is sort of the
journey of it of a character to see it
as this is a punishment and i've got to
prove that i'm innocent kind of thing
thank you yeah i mean i i think even in
even in comedy series on television one
thing i often find myself
reminding myself in my own projects and
telling other writers that come to me
and want feedback and stuff is that your
characters should really be in hell and
under siege pretty much all the time
like even if you watch a show like 30
rock i mean these are slightly dated
references now but like everybody loves
raymond but i could also talk about like
veep or glow or current series if you
really look at what's going on for the
characters that we're following it's
basically they're suffering
they're under siege they're in a sort of
hell and they're trying to get out of it
pretty much every episode for us as an
audience it's fun to watch it's fun to
watch their reactions to things and just
sort of how their characters operate and
interact in a comedy in a drama or a
thriller it's fun in a different way for
the audience it's fun for us it's never
fun for them
you know even in even in the you know
the the save the cat book the blake
snyder book he talks about the fun and
game section which is the first half of
act 2 in a screenplay in his world and i
think he makes some great points but the
fun and game section even in that
section of the movie which he calls fun
and games i'm all often telling people i
don't think your character should so
much be having fun or enjoying the
situation your characters are kind of
under siege even in the first half of
act two they're kind of struggling
suffering being punished by the
situation they're in the upside down
world they find themselves in the
problem or goal that they're trying to
resolve which they're an underdog and
they're overmatched and the world is not
giving them what they want that's pretty
much every story in my view in every
genre so
um
it's
it's it's interesting how often writers
tend to write scenes of characters kind
of getting along and kind of having
victories
and ice and i usually say that you know
in a story the victories generally only
come at the very end if they come
anywhere other than the very end they're
usually very short-lived and often
overshadowed by the bigger problem that
still demands resolution because what
keeps the drama or the comedy moving is
that sense of there's a problem i'm
trying to solve this problem there's
this goal i'm trying to reach this goal
problem and goal are kind of two sides
of the same thing some stories the goal
is just to solve the problem in other
stories the goal is its own positive
thing and the problem is i haven't
reached the goal so it's kind of like
problem slash goal i think of it as like
the same thing but that being difficult
and unresolved
and also changing and evolving and
usually getting worse and more
complicated over the course of the story
or the tv episode or this tv series
is kind of this key thing that i'm
always looking at i think audiences and
certainly industry professionals are
looking at and evaluating consciously or
not do i feel the problem is compelling
and big is it getting worse
you know are the characters struggling
is it changing and evolving but
generally in a direction of
worse and more difficult until the kind
of final battle at the end where the
resolution finally happens so that's why
problem is that word that i think i'm
always referring to when i'm talking
about a story